alles schmeckt besser mit hotsource
so sieht das ganze geschnitten aus
Olivenöl in der Pfanne und wenn das
ganze heiß ist können wir Zwiebeln
hineingehen genauso wie unsere
Knoblauchzehe im ganzen jetzt die Chilis
dazugeben man merkt wirklich direkt wie
das aufzieht als nächstes Paprika nicht
zu vergessen die Anschluss Chili jetzt
Zucker drüber einrühren und Tomaten dazu
Deckel drauf wenn ihr merkt es wird
weniger Feuchtigkeit in der Pfanne
löschen wir ab mit Apfelessig und kochen
lassen bis alles weich ist und so sieht
das aus wenn alles weich ist jetzt
füllen wir es in den Mixer
und wir mixen
machen wir mehr ein bisschen
nachjustieren am Geschmack bisschen
Limette noch jetzt können wir das ganze
nur noch in ein Gefäß natürlich vorher
ein bisschen auskochen sauber machen
dies das hier wisst bescheid und dann
können wir es in den Kühlschrank stellen
oder verschenken